"SPECIAL REPORT" ."
♪ ♪
GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
WASHINGTON, I'M JOHN ROBERTS.
THE ROLLER COASTER STORY OF
JUSSIE SMOLLETT TOOK AN
UNEXPECTED TURN AS CHARGES
AGAINST HIM WERE UNEXPECTEDLY
DROPPED.
IF THE ACTOR WAS ACCUSED BY
POLICE AND THE PROSECUTOR OF
STAGING A RACIAL AND HOMOPHOBIC
ATTACK BECAUSE HE WAS UNHAPPY
WITH HIS COMPENSATION ON THE
TELEVISION SHOW "EMPIRE."
HIS ATTORNEYS SAY THE 16 FELONY
COUNTS HAVE BEEN DISMISSED, THE
CASE SEALED AND HIS $10,000 BOND
FORFEITED TO THE CITY BUT DENIED
THAT A DEAL WAS MADE.
THE PROSECUTORS SAY THEY BELIEVE
SMOLLETT LIED ABOUT THE ATTACK
DESPITE DROPPING THE CHARGES, HE
SAYS HE'S BEEN TRUTHFUL AND
CONSISTENT SINCE DAY ONE.
THE CHICAGO MAYOR RAHM EMANUEL
SAID IT WAS A WHITEWASH OF
JUSTICE.
>> JUSSIE SMOLLETT WAS SCHEDULED
TO APPEAR IN COURT FOR 16 FELONY
COUNTS OF LYING BUT THEN IN
TODAY A SHOCKING TWIST, THE CASE
WAS SUDDENLY DROPPED.
CHICAGO'S POLICE SUPERINTENDENT
AND MAYOR RAHM EMANUEL ARE
SLAMMING THE COOK COUNTY STATE
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE FOR SUDDENLY
DROPPING 16 FELONY COUNTS OF
LYING TO POLICE AGAINST ACTOR
JUSSIE SMOLLETT.
>> THIS IS ALL OF THE NAME OF
SELF-PROMOTION, THIS IS A
WHITEWASH OF JUSTICE.
>> IT'S MR. SMOLLETT WHO
COMMITTED THIS HOAX, PERIOD.
IF HE WANTED TO CLEAR HIS NAME,
THE WAY TO DO THAT WAS IN A
COURT OF LAW.
>> IN AN EMERGENCY HEARING, THE
JUDGE GRANTED THE PROSECUTOR'S
REQUEST TO DROP CHARGES, IN A
STATEMENT THE COOK COUNTY
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE SAID AFTER
REVIEWING ALL OF THE FACTS AND
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE CASE
INCLUDING MR. SMOLLETT'S
VOLUNTEER SERVICE IN THE
COMMUNITY AND AGREEMENT TO
FORFEIT HIS BOND TO THE CITY OF
CHICAGO, WE BELIEVE THIS OUTCOME
IS JUSTICE AND APPROPRIATE
RESOLUTION TO THIS CASE.
>> I HAVE BEEN TRUTHFUL AND
CONSISTENT ON EVERY LEVEL SINCE
DAY ONE.
I WOULD NOT BE MY MOTHER'S SON
IF I WAS CAPABLE OF ONE DROP OF
WHAT I'VE BEEN ACCUSED OF.
>> SUPERINTENDENT EDDIE JOHNSON
SAID POLICE CARRIED OUT AN
INVESTIGATION WITH DOZENS OF
DETECTIVES AND CONCLUDED THAT
SMOLLETT CUT A $3500 CHECK TO
PRETEND TO BEAT HIM AND SAY THIS
IS MAGA COUNTRY.
SMOLLETT SAYS CHICAGO'S TOP COP
IS WRONG.
>> I HAVE NO IDEA WHERE THAT
CAME FROM WHICH IS WHY YOU
SHOULD ALLOW INVESTIGATION AND
ALLOW THE STATE TO INVESTIGATE A
CHARGE BEFORE YOU GO TO THE
PRESS.
>> EXECUTIVE PRODUCERS FOR THE
HIT SHOW CUT HIS FINAL CHARACTER
FROM THE FINAL TWO EPISODES OF
THE SEASON.
NOW 20TH CENTURY FOX IS STANDING
BY HIM WRITING IN THE STATEMENT
"JUSSIE SMOLLETT HAS ALWAYS
MAINTAINED HIS INNOCENCE AND WE
ARE GRATIFIED THAT ALL CHARGES
AGAINST THEM HAVE BEEN
DISMISSED."
THE COOK COUNTY STATES
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE NOW SAID IT
DID NOT EXONERATE HIM AND IT
STANDS BY CHICAGO POLICE, THE
CHARGES DROPPED IN EXCHANGE FOR